لاي مدى روايه الجيش الاسرائيلي بانه دمر
اكثر من 700 منصه صواريخ لحماس هي مساله
منطقيه اولا تدمير هذه المنظومه التي
يتحدث عنها الجيش الاسرائيلي واستمرار
اطلاق القذائف الى الداخل الاسرائيلي هذا
امر يناقض الى حد ما هذا لا يعني انه لم
يكن هناك خسائر ولكن دائما في هكذا نوع من
الحروب
الاستمراريه والعزيمه وبالتالي تامين
اللوجستيه يعني القدره على السيطره
الكوماند كنترول كما يقال القياده
والسيطره وبالتالي استعمال هذه المنظومه
من ضمن منظومه اكبر يعني على سبيل المثال
عندما نقول في اول يوم ب 7 اكتوبر تقول
المقاومه انها اطلقت 5000 صاروخ اسرائيل
تقول انها 300
3500 صاروخ ولكن تراجع هذا العدد بسبب
يعني مستلزمات امنيه مستلزمات تخدم
المعركه بشكل كامل يعني استمعنا الى وزير
الدفاع يقول عن تفعيل وحده الكلاب الاوكس
طيب او انه يقاتل في اماكن مختلفه هذا امر
طبيعي يعني
الاسرائيلي لم يتعود بالقتال التقليدي
وحتى القتال الهجين على هكذا نوع من ال
انه يتدرب كلما تقدم ولكن هذا التدريب
والوعي كلما تقدم يدفع ثمنه بالدم وهذا ما
يبرر عدد القتلى وعدد المعطوبين وعدد
الذين يعانون من امراض نفسيه كيف تقيم
مسار المعارك على محاور القتال في
القطاع هناك غنوه خطابين متناقضين للقياده
الاسرائيليه ان كانت العسكريه او السياسيه
هناك خطاب موجه للخارج على ان المعركه
ستدخل الى المرحله الثانيه او منخفضه
الحده وخطاب للداخل على ان الحرب مستمره
لاشهر ولكن ما يتبين اليوم ما يجري في
الشمال هو ليس كما الوسط وهو ليس كما
الجنوب حول خان يونس في الشمال انتقلت
اسرائيل الى او الجيش الاحتلال الى
المرحله الثالثه منخفضه الحده وهذا الامر
يتطلب تكتيك جديد ولكن التكتيك الذي
يستعمله الجيش الاسرائيلي عبر فك الاشتباك
والانسحاب والقيام بعمليات خاصه هو ايضا م
يعني فرصه معينه ووقت معين يسمح للمقاومه
ايضا بالتاق لم من هنا لم تتوقف العمليات
خاصه عندما استدرجت قوات المقاومه الجيوش
بعض الجنود الاسرائيليين الى النفق في
الوسط هناك عمليه حرب شرسه تدور حول
المخيمات وفصلها عن بعضها البعض بعض اما
خانيونس الهدف الاساسي هو المدينه اما شرق
خانيونس هو الهدف دائما هو تثبيت القوات
المقاومه الدمار الشامل والكامل وكان
الجيش الاسرائيلي يحضر لعمليه دمار تجريف
وبالتالي تامين ما يسمى او ما يريد ان
يحققه من منطقه عازله مع السياج او مع
الداخل الاسرائيلي برايك هل هذا التكتيك
في خان يونس سيختلف عما شهدناه في الشمال
مختلف تماما لان المساحه مختلفه مركز
القوه مختلف تعتبره مركز مركز ثقل اساسي
خانيونس خانيونس من يقاتل في خانيونس هم
من النخبه من يقاتل في خانيونس تعتبره
اسرائيل مركز ثقل وهذا يدل ان هذا القتال
الاخير يعني ما يجري في خانيونس سوف يحدد
المرحله صوره المرحله المقبله سياسيا
عسكريا وحتى استراتيجيا وحتى بالمعنى
السياسي بما ان عناصر المقاومه هم اصحاب
الارض الى اي مدى ربما هذه النقطه
تشكل مساله تقدم بالنسبه
لهم هي افضليه كما يقال بالانجليزيه الهوم
كورت يعني هو من يقاتل في بيته هو من اعد
هو يعي المكان والزمان البيئه مناصره له
وليس البيئه معاديه كل هذه العوامل
وبالتالي التحضير المصب يعني نحن نتحدث
عن الانفاق او شبكه الانفاق 500 ر تحت
الارض هذا الامر يعطي لاهل الدار انسيابيه
مختلفه عندما تطوق القوات الاسرائيليه
المقاومه هناك مخرج دائما للقتال للخروج
وحتى الهجوم على هذه القوات الاسرائيليه
من الخلف وضرب خطوط المواصلات واللوجستيه
ايضا شكرا لك من بيروت العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي